notre monde c'est squeeze avec une voix
de merde et aujourd'hui on se retrouve
en face sur the cure 7 forest en bon
français je dis enfin parce qu'en fait
ça fait des mois que vous conseiller ce
jeu parce que graphiquement il parle
c'est un truc de dingue et qu'aussi fait
plutôt peur donc je propose simplement
qu'on y joue une prochaine vidéo chat
mon piste ok c'est parti on vient
d'apparaître juste là et je propose
qu'on y reste
voilà j'ai toujours de bonnes idées
comme ça c'est gratuit un bon bah
écoutez on était bien poser mais je
crois que il faut partie aventure
[ __ ] c'est joli hein c'est pas très
rassurant mais c'est joli j'espère
qu'ils vont pas trop me faire forcer sur
ma voix de frayeur à étant donné qu'elle
est déjà un petit peu fragile
jean-françois tous les soirs je mets un
petit peu de crème dessus
est-ce que partout hasard on va pas
trouvé un pistolet à fusées éclairantes
comme dans ce fort est vraiment bien
alors gauche ou droit de premier choix
et je fais toujours des choix nul la
bayanne les autres on va aller là-bas
vous allez voir ça va être le mauvais
choix bien évidemment comme à chaque
fois donc je vais pas tomber dans les
orties et mourir maintenant quand même
non c'est bon donc là bas on n'ira
jamais je préfère le dire aux hommes et
à quelqu'un si c'est sur oa ça c'est une
aire pardon dans la maison y at il
quelqu'un qui dort au bateau mais yakaré
mieux et carmaux un meurtre de sangliers
la [ __ ] mais qu'est-ce qu'on a une
lettre alors il ya une histoire de
pierre de rituels que je dois trouver et
récupérer
donc moi on va se contenter de ça
puisque façon c'est ce truc j'ai réussi
à traduire
bah voilà ça c'est quoi ces des poissons
du rituel c'est parfait non je suis déçu
est-ce que je peux apprendre cette
petite lampe à tout hasard
bien sûr que non ce petit poisson en
guise de matraques bien sûr que non tu
as le joueur préféré ne jamais découvrir
cette maison quoi sans déconner
oui un brusque à hockey ne crient le
plus viril du monde avec la voix que
j'ai quoi c'est incroyable ah c'est un
générateur pour allumer juste qu'une
seule l'ambiance juste pour faire
plaisir aux petites lucioles aux
papillons aux insectes bombe en valais
par là haut au nom au nom j'ai dit j'ai
dit qu'on faisait pas de force électoral
petite voix s'il vous plaît c'est au nom
d'elle je parle à son nom
bah voilà sa nouvelle maison on est
posée il est petit bruit grenouille
c'est bien des grenouilles à dubaï un
peu bon le pourra pas se casse le pont
va se casser
ah c'est sûr c'est sûr et il n'y a pas
de bon d'accord c'est encore plus simple
à la nage
on peut nager vraiment plus ça je
pensais pas allez on y va
hop alors qu'est ce que c'est que ça
ramasse l'os d'accord moi j'ai ramassé
un homme et l'a obligé il ya un [ __ ]
de requins qui va arriver qu'à faire
beau oh puis je décède
je suis mort y avait des yeux sort de
l'eau mon gars cool j'ai vu deux yeux
cette [ __ ] de grenouille je suis sûr
vous êtes très belle juste une blague
d'accord vous n'êtes pas du tout brillé
c'est au prix de grenouilles de merde eh
ben c'est bien on a un os et je
maintenant je rentre à la maison
bon bah allez par la csa schéma qui leur
est droite ou gauche gauche cette fois o
o
non non non mais je voulais à la droite
moi je vais aller à droite c'est quoi ça
là bas
le réflexe de l'homme coup qu'est ce que
c'est que ça bah c'est un tronc d'arbre
ça me plaît à bompas caché dedans
remarques à la barre qu'est ce que c'est
que ça la main sacré sur un trône rouge
on voit rien on voit rien [ __ ] moi
[ __ ] de rien ou [ __ ] voit rien
j'aurais dû prendre à droite je me
trouvais ce bras squelette je le savais
je crois qu'il faut trouver les restes
de la petite fille et des pierres de
rituels pour pouvoir faire un rituel et
purger son âme d'innocence ça doit être
à peu près de quelque chose comme ça gm
souhaite un présentateur télé avec cette
voix bienvenue d'un four et à tous la
nouvelle émission qui cartonne
nulle part dans le monde on applaudit
bien fort nos invités le baril un peu
psychopathe
on n'a plus les bienfaits le deuxième
invité qui est donc le second bras
regardez regardez c'est pas deux petits
yeux d'avoir gardé quand je bouge dirais
qu'il ya deux petits yeux ou alors c'est
un bug graphique n'a c'est un [ __ ] de
monstres jeté comme un imposteur
on applaudit bien fort le troisième
invité le monstre chiant qui poussent
des barils dans nos jambes mais je ferai
de repasser par là il est juste la
droite [ __ ] seul petit le kit filles
dans 3 2 1
allez on n'est pas ce et john monstre
nul quelque part un passage a été ouvert
bas c'est génial quelque part jose de
[ __ ] de forêt de 8 hectares le mec me
dit quelque part dans la forêt un
pissenlit à pousser merci le narrateur
est inexistant du jeune homme et j'ai vu
je rêve pas il ya bien un [ __ ] de
monstres on l'a vu qu'on était dans
l'eau et on l'a vu après tu te calmes de
suite et tu rejoins l'émission soit tu
restes dans sa tanière
il ya trois chemins à mon gars il ya
trois mois
je déteste les décisions que j'ai prises
celui de droite rien il est beaucoup
vous n'avez pas collecter tous les items
nécessaires auxquels je veux pas par là
j'ai compris le celui du milieu on
appris celui qui fait un peu chemin vtt
avec ses copains mais qui finit en
fracture du crâne avec ses copains ok
vous n'êtes pas collecter tous les items
nécessaire j'ai pris ce chemin tout à
gauche du cou est-ce que oh ça ne peut
plus durer
oh il ya eu des petits au nom à temps
pourquoi cette herbe décide de se casser
à moitié quand moi j'arrive je suis sûr
qu'il va tomber sur moi c'est sûr a
voilà il serait tombé sur moi vous
pensez je sais pas mais j'ai pas du tout
envie de tester je vous avais dit ça
allait partir en fracture du crâne bon
je l'avais dit on peut pas brûler quand
même non ça va alors une autre maison
voilà en mon dieu qu'est ce qu'on a fait
c'est pas ce à quoi nous nous attendions
ma femme à deux ris devenue folle on
marie je t'aime
pardonne moi pour tout à moi en tout cas
je pardonne pas parce que si le mousseux
chelou que j'ai vu c'est à fann [ __ ]
je te pardonne pas qu'est-ce qu'on a une
deuxième pièce sur laquelle on peut
s'amuser à sauter sur le lit à temps on
peut on attend mais quels étaient les
architectes cette maison encore une fois
quand il ya casser le rêve de plein
d'enfants pick-up stone
oh vous l'avez vu cette chose était un
monstre ou une paire de lucioles
diabolique a du coup on a une pierre
c'est très bien ça regarde je fais de
mettre 60
on sent belle symphonie pas aux cas qui
est un générateur
il ya quelque chose dans l'eau je
donnais boulounencs ya un [ __ ] de truc
dans l'eau je n'irai pas dans l'eau il
faut que je fasse parle au nom d avoir
un chemin de type escalade
non juste un chemin de type de piscine
vous sent pas il va nous noyer a mais ça
va on a pied à massa va alors bah oui
enfin ça va ah non mais c'est un bateau
pardon pardon
mais c'est bien ça mais non mais non au
nom et d'un haut mais c'est ça c'est la
petite fille
renault trucks back and the shadow bas
merci d'avoir les questions en anglais
voilà le temps de traduire c'était fini
mais en fait là elle est tapi au fond de
l'eau c'est ça aide à temps comme ça
tranquillement sans respirer j'ai fait
marcher sur le crâne voilà ça c'est
bruit de quelqu'un qui marche sur le
crâne oui je t'ai vu je t'ai vu tu es
très belle lui était charmante ces
partis cours je regarde pas des à moi
c'est ça pour toi courir
c'est bon on a passé le tronc d'arbre on
sait qu'il a passé le trône armes et à
la passe est trop d'arbres je cours bien
trop vite pour toi regarde ça se voit
bon dieu tout s'écroule royal chanson
d'horreur comme ça qu'ils mettront la
pression ma tête a tendance à baisser
petit à petit ces bombes et à tuer
dessinée a nagé avec les grenouilles à
terme 100 dos anjos hors d'eau ah ça
fait du bien de retrouver la terre ferme
moi je passe par là voilà je suis à même
à fougères c'est la montée fatale à ckoi
c'est quoi c'est quoi cette histoire
encore
fracture du crâne mais s'ils veulent
rocher il est dans l'eau il a tué
l'ombre démoniaque
merci rocher au ya un autre tremblement
attend mais dans la forêt les restes
d'une petite fille
la forêt fait huit hectares il ya des
maisons abandonnées et en plus
sollicités sur une plaque s'explique ça
va il ya des feux allumés là comme si un
mec était venu évaluer jeu pour nous
faire peur et que c'est son métier quoi
touchant un smic tous les mois pour
allumer des feux et partir en courant et
pas une petite pierre de rituels ou un
petit os par là c'est une demande un peu
chelou je suis tout à fait conscient ok
en fait les faits cette verte et
checkpoint suis un peu confuse juste
aller dessus et mourir à marbre mourir
le screamer de type palette ça suffit
jeunes palais tu ne fera plus jamais ça
tu tu me dis toute seule petite cage
thoracique ça me plaît ça ou là ça part
en escalade et au plais à mon expérience
est fort et je faisais de l' escalade
avec mes deux meilleurs amis
voilà ça se voir merde on est pas mal on
n'est pas morts on a juste deux jambes
cassées quelque part un passage s'est
ouvert est ce que tu pourrais pas jouer
des coordonnées une boussole avec ok
donc on est revenu au point de départ
je sais qu'à sûreté attention lâcheté
racines bon c'était une menace nul
qu'est ce que c'est que ça f orio une
grille in the apple fmb une pomme
soupçons nathan mec c'est un piège c'est
un piège je sais que le monde nous
regarde quelque part et qu'on va manger
l'info mais vas kiffer il va faire il
est tombé dans le piège de ouf
mais vu curieux je mangeais cette pomme
et voilà c'est pas un piège au maire au
nom
ok donc le salut fis pas de me voir
agoniser elle vient trancher la gorge
tranquillement mecs sur sa route il ya
un saut avec une pomme en dessous lso il
se dit car si j'avais faim non piège à
la con ça ne marchera pas cette fois bon
du coup je fais 30 cm de plus pas mal
peut-être que je suis un peu plus peur
aux monstres est ce qu'il y aurait pas
moyen de trouver dans ce puits sont une
trottinette 1 pour les quatre fois plus
vite on accès aux trucs de droite
bonjour c'est ici le passage que j'ai
débloqué watts que c'est que ce gaz vers
la haye de l'inseec j'aime les insectes
doit bien avoir un truc à part à tétouan
[ __ ] pigeons nadja plein paris alors
tu te tais bordel y avait une lumière
rouge dans son amant son fils de chien
fils de chien je mets à la gorge une
passion pour la gorge vous plaît
secrétaire je n'ai pas de secrétaire pas
grave à la mayenne jambes bien de quatre
heures la bayard quatre heures j'imagine
bien mec dans un marécage
il ya juste à tête qui les passe comme
ça il faut bien de crier secrétaire le
deuxième par un merde juste fougères
jeté une grenouille
ah non c'est quoi ça ces insectes en
pause très bien professeur xavier
arrêter le temps petite dégustation
gratuite d'insectes qu'est-ce que je
fais là mais tu siffles fait de
l'accrobranche tu vas fort de cette
plante devant moi sont avec nous f k me
cattoir
4 saloperie de merde allez un mur
invisible
ces pigeons vous avez entendu un bruit
de pigeons juste avant non non non elle
nous a vus vous avez quoi nous regarde
là un peu tassé spada lumière normale ça
c'est de la lumière genre mais je t'ai
vu regardez elle fait [ __ ] mais des
fois il ne frôle les cheveux quoi joue
le même si elle me les caresses pas au
passage comme pour me dire bonne chance
petite merde je crois qu'elles partent
se coucher
les partis se coucher france à sa barre
toi bartois barre toi partout à part toi
barbara mais voilà on a fait le clida
petite fille de 8 ans prévue du début de
la vidéo c'est là je m'en bats les
stations france depuis 15 jours
elle arrive elle arrive elle arrive oh
non non non non je respire par les
fesses actuellement ça va passer je le
sais qu il n a pas pu suivre en dehors
de ma cage non barils
la transpiration se fait ressentir la
chambre de lucas c'est le talent de dire
et encore le saut on va retourner au
passage du milieu voire même si je pense
qu'il n'y a absolument rien à moins que
un ours en peluche c'est c'est quoi ces
c'est pas un os c'est quoi c'est une
pierre non c'était un chef rouge non je
ne rabats serait pas cette chose ça
c'est là la cabane un peu flippante qu'y
at-il dans cette cabane
déjà on ne saura jamais ce qu'on peut
pas aller dedans non peux pas le dire se
reconnaît un haut à le sens plus jeune
et plus là j'aurais leurs chants plus je
te reverrai avaient tous les soirs je
lui ferai ce même sans toilettes
je pense tout bas il ya un truc au pied
de l'arbre pick-ups toon boom a je crois
qu'on est en train de casser un cheval
au bail sauvage c'est le saut avec la
pomme ça ne marchera pas oui bah les
jours c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur
youtube sur cette forêt j'espère que
vous aurez plus c'est qu'elle n'est pas
muette dos apparemment plaisir j'suis
désolé mais là je peux pas continuer
parce que je force de plus en plus sur
ma voix est en deuil je crée de plus en
plus et c'est surtout pas à cause de ce
crime heures qui m'appellent tous fait
peur hein que j'arrête mes bons opa quoi
si vous voulez qu'on finisse le jeu donc
une deuxième vidéo n'hésitait pas à dire
en commentaire sur toute évidence
nouvelle vidéo chat monde
pis je m'en vais dans mon appartement